السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته so farد العمين
‏more if not them
into let
not have all
around
and you beach
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
لاه الله اكبر الله
اكبر اله الا
الله استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا استعينوا بالصبر
والصلاه ان الله مع
الصابرين ولا تقولوا لمن يقتل في سبيل
الله
اموات بل
احياء ولكن لا
تشعرون
ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من
الاموال ونقص من الاموال
والانفس والثمرات
وبشر
الصابرين وبشر الصابرين الذين اذا
اصابتهم
مصيبه
قالوا قالوا انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون
اولئك عليهم
صلوات من ربهم ورحمه
واولئك هم
المهتدون ان الصفا والمروه من شعائر الله
فمن حج البيت واعتمر فلا جناح عليه ان
يطوف
بهما ومن تطوع
خيرا فان الله شاكر عليم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين ان الذين يكتمون ما انزلنا من
البينات والهدى من بعد ما
بيناه للناس في
الكتاب
اولئك يلعنهم
الله
اولئك يلعنهم الله ويلعنهم
اللاعنون الا الذين تابوا واصلحوا وبينوا
فاولئك اتوب
عليهم
فاولئك اتوب عليهم وانا التواب
الرحيم ان الذين كفروا وماتوا وهم كفار
اولئك
اولئك عليهم لعنه الله
والملائكه والناس
اجمعين خالدين
فيها لا يخفف عنهم العذاب ولا هم
ينظرون والهكم
اله
واحد لا اله الا هو الرحمن الرحيم
الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم
الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه اللهم
[Silence]
அஸலாமு
அலைக்கும் மடிய பிரதர்
சிஸ்டர் கிவ்ய அப்டேட்ஸ்
মামলা
কud
anyবশ
হারফ 7
‏other 8:30 am so something makeat 7 am
and 830 am so we going try to see if we
can stay close to the schedle because
our conra is the people coming next
door going in their cars also the church
serv on so we are going first we going
do we have deci not to use their par
‏and we have cleared our own par
are on the sou of us and also we have
some ne par ne lot that is made avilable
now for us to to u for par additional
paring so we have we believe we have
ample paring spaces if we follow the
guidance from the people that will be
helping us that day so we have eight
people will
ே so
gu atly morning
6 so be car that comes in is only coming
to our not in the neb lot that's number
one number two that we have to follow
pleas to that when they gu you to go
certain dire please do so because we
have a plan we can manage all cars ‏com
in but you par if you don't us we can
get in trou so again follow the rules
and if there any question come and see
me or insall fig
out we have
theat to make that is
pa person for every m in your
household boxes available here there is
a credit c ma on the wall and there you
can check
‏care will be after the
sal have the kids there going be
jumpingle st also will be some the bref
is avilable that's all going to happ
after the second pray the conclusion of
the second prayer will have all these
activities so if you come in the first
prayer and you would to benit
‏from hang around or come back but pleas
make sure you help us with the parking
rotation and all that st so at 9 o will
have the breakfast for everybody you
know actually after 8:30 as soon as the
s finished breakfast will be available
and the kids can go play the in the in
the parking lot
insall and tables and chairs will be set
up outside the gymnasium
‏any
جزاكم الله خيرا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
‏some
paran
[Silence]
comp after
‏So since there noح take time and start
giving out the gift tomorrow ان so what
I recommend from you guys is the
الحمد is over but do stick around these
kids have put a lot of effort in I mean
seen
todayolds you knowingas that most of us
would be hitant toite in sal or just by
ourselves so it's an aming to see so be
around and encourage
‏happ انء الله انء الله
30 جزاك الله
خير استقيم واعتدل واستو
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا استو
‏sister if
you and have socializing pleas in
the outside
the whole of sister in the fray and
listen to qu and if you don't do
thatine this is notigated to be here so
you can talk as much as you want
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف
الليل
والنهار واختلاف الليل والنهار والفلك
التي تجري في البحر بما ينفع
الناس وما انزل الله من
السماء من
ماء فاحيا به الارض بعد
موتها وبث فيها من كل
دابه وتصريف الرياح والسحاب المسخر ر بين
السماء والارض
لايات لايات لقوم
يعقلون ومن الناس من يتخذ من دون الله
اندادا يحبونهم كحب
الله والذين امنوا اشد حبا
لله ولو يرى الذين ظلموا اذ يرون
العذاب ان القوه لله
جميعا وان الله شديد
العذاب اذ تبرا الذين اتبعوا من الذين
اتبعوا وراوا
العذاب وراوا العذاب وتقطعت بهم
الاسباب وقال الذين اتبعوا لو ان
كره فنتبرا منهم فنتبرا منهم كما تبراوا
منا كذلك يريهم الله اعمالهم حسرات
عليهم وما هم بخارجين من
النار يا
ايها الناس كلوا مما في الارض حلالا
طيبا ولا تتبعوا خطوات الشيطان انه لكم
عدو
مبين انما
يامركم
بالسوء
والفحشاء وان
تقولوا وان تقولوا على الله ما لا تعلمون
واذا قيل لهم اتبعوا ما انزل الله
قالوا قالوا بل نتبع ما الفينا عليه
اباءنا اولو كان
اباؤهم لا يعقلون شيئا ولا
يهتدون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومثل الذين كفروا كمثل الذي ينعق بما
لا يسمع الا
دعاء
ونداء صم بكم عمي فهم لا يعقلون
يا ايها الذين امنوا كلوا من طيبات ما
رزقناكم واشكروا لله ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم
الخنزير ولحم الخنزير وما اهل به لغير
الله فمن اضطر غير باغ ولا عاد فلا اثم
عليه ان الله غفور
رحيم ان الذين يكتمون ما انزل الله من
البينات ان الذين يكتمون ما انزل الله من
الكتاب ويشترون به ثمنا قليلا
اولئك ما ياكلون في بطونهم الا
النار ولا يكلمهم الله يوم القيامه ولا
يزكيهم ولهم عذاب اليم ذلك
اولئك الذين اشتروا الضلاله بالهدى
والعذاب
بالمغفره فما ما اصبرهم على النار ذلك بان
الله نزل الكتاب
بالحق وان الذين اختلفوا في الكتاب لفي
شقاق بعيد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
الضالين
امين ليس البر ان تولوا وجوهكم قبل المشرق
والمغرب
ولكن البر من امن بالله واليوم الاخر
والملائكه والكتاب
والنبيين واتى المال على حبه
ذوي القربى واليتامى والمساكين وابن
السبيل واليتامى والمساكين وابن السبيل
والسائلين وفي
الرقاب واقام الصلاه واتى الزكاه والموفون
بعهدهم اذا
عاهدوه والصابرين في الباساء
والصابرين في
الباساء
والضراء وحين الباس اولئك الذين صدقوا
واولئك هم
المتقون يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم
القصاص في
القتلى الحر بالحر والعبد بالعبد والانثى
بالانثى فمن عفي له من اخيه شيء
فاتباع
بالمعروف
فاتباع بالمعروف واداء اليه
باحسان ذلك تخفيف من ربكم ورحمه فمن اعتدى
بعد ذلك فله عذاب
اليم ولكم في القصاص حياه يا اولي
الالباب ولكم في القصاص
حياه يا اولي الالباب لعلكم
تتقون كتب عليكم اذا حضر احدكم الموت ان
ترك ان ترك خيرا
الوصيه ان ترك خيرا
الوصيه للوالدين والاقربين بالمعروف حقا
على
المتقين فمن بدله بعد ما سمعه
فانما فانما اثمه على الذين
يبدلونه ان الله سميع عليم فمن خاف من موص
جنفا او اثما فاصلح
بينهما فاصلح بينهم فاصلح بينهم فلا اثم
عليه ان الله غفور رحيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعم ت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم
الصيام كما كتب على الذين من قبلكم لعلكم
تتقون اياما
معدودات فمن كان منكم مريضا او على سفر
فعده من ايام
اخر وعلى الذين
يطيقونه فديه طعام
مسكين وفمن تطوع خيرا فهو خير له وان
تصوموا خير
ان كنتم
تعلمون شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه
القران هدى للناس
وبينات من الهدى
والفرقان فمن شهد منكم الشهر
فليصمه ومن كان مريضا او على سفر
فعده من ايام اخر يريد الله بكم اليسر ولا
يريد بكم العسر ولتكملوا العده ولتكبروا
الله على ما
هداكم ولعلكم
تشكرون واذا سالك عبادي
عني فاني
قريب فاني قريب
اجيب دعوه الداع اذا
دعان
فليستجيبوا لي
وليؤمنوا بي لعلهم يرشدون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول
الله وعلى اله وصحبه
منولاه ومن تبعه
باحسان الى يوم
[Silence]
‏So we just focus on just coule of
things
today first and
forem there was a
discussion in the office earli
‏And there was a point up the رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
وسلم من صام رمضان ايمانا
واحتسابا ثم اتبع من
شوال
فغفرانه صام
الظهر حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏and of we look at this way that fasting
the 30 days 29 days the is times 10 so
that's you know 290 and you add 6 more
60 that gets you close to you know 360
days appr for the whole year
insall and as was
[Silence]
مكال
any
differ and increase
‏and how different have looked at
this
topic so my recommendation usually is if
you if you talked to me years pri my
recation is start on monday again and
this way you're done by
Saturday is laughing I know I say this
every year start the day after and
finish it that weekend that's
‏out
of there is no there no yes or no to
fasting and it makes it go faster and
before you know it the whole week is
done for you and this way you're not now
there are some
other who say that you should be doing
it the fast in the week and do it that
way and finish it out whatever is
convenient for you do
[Silence]
‏as
so never been at i not mention had in in
open pres with the conregation and
صل
الله سبحانه
وتالى ايد ايد الفطر
الاضحى الاضحى الله سبحانه وتالى
‏am because this is time are more heat
any other time
around you
people
cyx
people are out and about what
‏Jing
off and said we
can technically you know after all toay
so you canchallyay tomorrow if you want
to but you know somebody brother to so
قام
قيام
4 16
ركع صلاه
الفجر صلاه
العيد ‏That's it. We're just asking you
for to get up just a little bit
earlier. But the reality of our of our
human mindset is that when it's done,
it's done. We someh you know there is a
famous saying scholar who says that you
know
Ramadan you know the Lord of
Ramadan is also the Lord of the Shawal
and and the months to come. ‏But in our
mind the lord of Ramadan is subhanallah
is the most you know powerful and the
most you know we need to be careful of
and then after that it's
okay don't worry about it let's continue
as it
is the second on this toic mentions that
stands up the two nights of
the
forال الله let their heart die when
people are
dead what
غفله
peopleستقيم الله سبحانه
وتالى take
mindfulان doesn't
mean because over doesn't
تهجد ماء
الله مصحف
ரஹ
انء
الله start
مصحف new at least make the intention as
we sit in the j today as we sit here
make the intention you don't have to
move your make the intention
[Silence]
الله mindful
আল্লাহ
present the laws of are there haveations
to
‏and areful life and here and from
theell
oures mother and father and those have
upon and those have upon us and all are
people are the best
الله make
people take
away
make
محمد ofران
‏further until we are
not for us and this
beautiful brothers and sisters victory
in and in China and inma and in hind and
everywh else the Muslims are suffered or
being oppressed may Allah aid them
through the
aven do not know exist we ask
Allah to protect this community first
and forem
‏comm
all
commysally and
finally and this
beau
further as much
as ربنا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار وكنا عذاب القبر وكنا عذاب جهنم
وكنا شر فتنه محل الممات وكنا شر فتنه
المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا كواب الرحيم
صلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللهم امين
[Silence]
استو استوه استووا
اعتدلوا
استووا الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
احل لكم ليله الصيام الرفث الى
نسائكم هن لباس لكم وانتم لباس
لهن علم الله انكم كنتم تختانون انفسكم
فتاب عليكم وعفى
عنكم فالان
باشروهن وابتغوا ما كتب الله لكم وكلوا
واشربوا حتى يتبين لكم الخيط الابيض من
الخيط الاسود من
الفجر ثم اتموا الصيام الى
الليل ولا
تباشروهن وانتم عاكفون في
مساجد تلك حدود الله فلا
تقربوها كذلك يبين الله اياته للناس لعلهم
يتقون ولا تاكلوا اموالكم بينكم بالباطل
وتدلوا بها الى الحكام لتاكلوا
فريقا لتاكلوا فريقا من اموال الناس
بالاثم وانتم
تعلمون يسالونك عن
الاهله قل هي مواقيت للناس
والحج وليس البر بان تاتوا البيوت من
ظهورها ولكن البر من
اتقى واتوا البيوت من ابوابها واتقوا الله
لعلكم تفلحون
وقاتلوا في سبيل الله الذين
يقاتلونكم ولا
تعتدوا ان الله لا يحب
المعتدين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
بركب الحمد لله رب العالمين امين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وقاتلوا في سبيل الله الذين يقاتلونكم ولا
تعتدوا ان الله لا يحب
المعتدين واقتلوهم حيث ثقفتموهم واخرجوهم
من حيث
اخرجوكم والف الفتنه اشد من القتل ولا
تقاتلوهم عند المسجد الحرام حتى يقاتلوكم
فيه فان قاتلوكم فاقتلوهم كذلك
جزاء
الكافرين
فانوا فان الله غفور
رحيم وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه
ويكون الدين
لله فانوا فلا عدوان الا على
الظالمين الشهر الحرام بالشهر الحرام
والحرمات
قصاص فمن اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل
ما اعتدى عليكم واتقوا الله واعلموا ان
الله مع المتقين
وانفقوا في سبيل الله ولا تلقوا بايديكم
الى التهلكه
واحسنوا ان الله يحب
المحسنين واتموا الحج والعمره
لله فان احصرتم فما استيسر من الهدي ولا
تحلقوا رؤوسكم حتى يبلغ الهدي
محله فمن كان
منكم مريضا او به اذى من راسه ففديه من
صيام او صدقه او
نسك فاذا
امنتم فمن تمتع بالعمره الى الحج فما
استيسر من
الهدي فمن لم يجد فصيام ثلاثه ايام في
الحج وسبعه اذا
رجعتم تلك عشره
كامله ذلك لمن لم يكن اهله حاضر المسجد
الحرام واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله شديد
العقاب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الحج اشهر
معلومات فمن فرض فيهن الحج فلا رفث ولا
فسوق ولا جدال في الحج
وما تفعلوا من خير يعلمه
الله وتزودوا فان خير الزاد التقوى
واتقوني يا اولي
الالباب ليس عليكم جناح ان تبتغوا فضلا من
ربكم فاذا افضتم من
عرفات فاذكروا الله عند المشعر
الحرام واذكروه كما هداكم وان كنتم من
قبله لمن
الضالين ثم افيضوا من حيث افاض الناس
واستغفروا
الله ان الله غفور
رحيم فاذا قضيت م مناسككم فاذكروا الله
كذكركم
اباءكم او اشد
ذكرا فمن الناس من يقول ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا وما له في الاخره من
خلاق ومنهم من يقول ربنا اتنا في الدنيا
حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب
النار
اولئك لهم نصيب مما
كسبوا والله سريع
الحساب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذكروا الله في ايام
معدودات فمن تعجل في يومين فلا اثم عليه
ومن تاخر فلا اثم عليه لمن اتقى واتقوا
الله واعلموا انكم اليه
تحشرون ومن الناس من يعجبك قوله في الحياه
الدنيا ويشهد
الله ويشهد الله على ما في قلبه وهو الد
الخصام واذا تولى سعى في الارض ليفسد فيها
ويهلك الحرث
والنسل والله لا يحب
الفساد واذا قيل له اتق الله اخذته العزه
بالاثم فحسبه جاه
جهنم فحسبه
جهنم ولبئس
المهاد ومن الناس من يشري نفسه
ابتغاء مرضاه
الله والله رؤوف
بالعباد يا ايها الذين امنوا ادخلوا في
السلم
كافه ولا تتبعوا
خطوات
الشيطان انه لكم عدو
مبين فان
زللتم من بعد ما
جاءتكم البينات
فاعلموا فاعلموا ان الله عزيز
حكيم هل ينظرون الا ان ياتيهم الله في ظلل
من الغمام
والملائكه وقضي
الامر والى الله ترجع
الامور الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله شف استو
ப்ப இய
‏Pleas the lines in front of
you. There's a hole in front of you in
the line. Please that there's one more
spot at the end over there.
الخل الله سبحانه وتعالى امين الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
امين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لايلاف
قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا البيت
الذي اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله اكبر